[Musique]
la tradition de la rentrée solennelle
remonte à une quinzaine d'années je
crois que j'ouvrirai la 16e édition de
la rentrée solennelle c'est pour nous
l'occasion de remettre des distinctions
à nos majors de promotion c'est un
diplôme de major particulier que l'on
remet aux étudiants les plus méritants
c'est l'occasion aussi pour nous de le
remettre des ouvrages pour les aider à
approfondir leurs cours et anticiper les
matières qu'ils suivront les années
suivantes
[Musique]
le doyen lors de cette rentrée
solennelle a pour rôle de faire le bilan
de l'année qui vient de s'achever et de
faire le point sur les projets en cours
il y a des projets évidemment de
développement de nos formations
notamment orientées vers les doubles
licences il y a le chantier qui
s'annonce autour de la sélection des
étudiants en Master 1 il y a également
des projets beaucoup plus originaux de
développement de la proposition
culturelle à nos étudiants notamment en
lien avec les cinémas les théâtres du
département et c'est dans les tablettes
également avec la presse
[Musique]